ونحييكم من جديد دفع المنطقه والعالم لنمو
الازدهار استراتيجيه صعوديه لطالما تحدث
عنها المسؤولون السعوديون ودعوا اليها وهو
ما ترجمه لاتفاق السعودي الايراني والاخير
والذي يعد فرصه لمد جسور التعاون والعمل
المشترك والذي سينعكس على جمله من قضايا
المنطقه اتفاق العاشر من مارس بين
السعوديه وايران بواسطه الصين والذي يقضي
باستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه حظيه
بترحيب عربي ودولي دول خليجيه وعربيه
وغربيه فضلا عن العديد من المنظمات
والهيئه الدوليه تفاعلت بشكل سريع مع
الاعلان بالاتفاق ورحبت به كونها خطوه
مهمه للمنطقه نحو الاستقرار والازدهار
الترحيب لا شك ان مرده الثقل الامني
والسياسي والاقتصادي للسعوديه وايران وان
كانت طهران تعاني من مشكله اقتصاديه عديده
كما ان الاتفاق ياتي تتويجا لرؤيه
الجانبين الصعود والايراني باولويه الحوار
لخفض التوتر ما سينعكس مع الوقت على
الملفات الشائكه في الشرق الاوسط
وكل ما نطمح له انه يكون لدينا علاقه طيبه
ومميزه مع ايران
لا نريد
وضع ايران يكون صعب بالعكس مزدهره تنمو
لدينا مصالح فيها لديهم مصالح الذين مصالح
فيها لديهم مصالح المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لدفع المنطقه والعالم النمو
والازدهار اشكالياتنا هي في تصرفات
السلبيه التي تقوم فيها ايران سواء من
برنامجها النووي او دعمها لمليشيات خارجه
على القانون في بعض دول المنطقه
الى ضيوفي محمد العنقريه كاتب الصحفي
العميد الدكتور خالد عكاشه الفكر ودراسات
الاستراتيجيه واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
الاستاذ من نصف وزير الاعلام سابقا استاذ
سامي منذ قليل المحنه بطريقه سريعه الى
دور الصيني ولكن وهو موضوع في الواقع
ناقشناه نحن بالامس في بانوراما ولكن وددت
سماع راي حضرتك عن هذه الوساطه واهميه ان
تكون الصين حاضره في علاقه مع الاقتصاد
كون الصين هو شريك اقتصادي واستراتيجي مهم
جدا للطرفين ايران والسعوديه كذلك ما مدى
اهميه الصين
انا اتصور انه الاهميه كبرى يعني الصين
كانت قوه اقتصاديه كبرى وكان لها دور
سياسي اقل شانا الان تفعيل الدور الصيني
لربما يذهب الى خطوات متسارعه الى الامام
نعلم ان اسيا هي القاره الوحيده اللي لا
يوجد بها تجمع قاري هناك الاتحاد الافريقي
الاتحاد الاوروبي النافذه اتحاد الدول
امريكا اللاتينيه لربما الان ضمن هذا
التحرك نرى تحرك اسيوي لخلق مجلس تعاون
لربما اسيوي
يساعد اسيا على حل مشاكلها نعلم ان هناك
رؤيه سعوديه استراتيجيه صائبه ترى ان
المناطق تنهض بالمجمل يعني نذكر بعد
الخمسه واربعين ان المانيا لم تنهض لوحدها
نهضت معها دول اوروبا الغربيه الحال كذلك
مع دول شرق اسيا الحال كذلك بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي والمت التي تمت في
اوروبا الشرقيه دائما تنهض الدول بشكل
جماعي وبالتالي علينا ان نعمل ضمن هذه
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه ومن ثم ايران وحتى
تركيا هي ضمن الجوار وضمن المنطقه واعتقد
ان ايران ضمن هذا التحرك الصيني والتحرك
السعودي هي امام مفترق طرق اما ان تنضم
للركب وللقاطره القائمه بدول ضمن دول
الخليج الاخرى والمملكه
ومحاوله النهوض بالمنطقه ككل واما هناك
المدن الاخر اللي هو كوريا الشماليه
الدوله المنعزله الدوله المقاطعه من قبل
المجتمع الدولي الدوله التي لا نسمع عنها
الا تهديدها للجيران بالاسلحه النوويه هذا
مثال لا يعني لا نحلم ولا نطمح ان تكون ان
يكون هذا مستقبل ايران ايران دوله شقيقه
ودوه نعلم في شكل يومي يعني نختلط بالا
شعب رائع وشعب جميل ودوله ذات حضاره بل ان
من
لحاق ايران بالركب يمكن تسويق المنطقه
بشكل جماعي نعلم ان ايران بها الكثير مما
يمكن للسائح ولا المستثمر ان يستثمر فيه
ويرى الحال بالعراق المملكه دول الخليج
الاردن سوريا لبنان نحن يعني منطقه يمكن
لها ان تكون بالفعل اوروبا اخرى ويمكن لها
ان تنهض بشكل كبير الان الكره لدى ايران
نامل ونرجو انه نرى يعني تحرك ايجابي من
ايران محاوله تبريد او تفكيك انا ارى انه
حتى بالمده هذه قاعدين نرى تفكيك بقضيه
الاشكال اليمنيه اليوم بجنيفه هناك لقاءات
هناك كذلك نوع من التحريك للملف السوري
هناك اجتماع الدول الاربع وبالتالي اذا
حسنت النوايا انا اعتقد انه تحتاج الا الى
فتره قصيره جدا
لرؤيه العلاقه مزدهره نعم قربت بين الخليج
واوروبا قد ينتقدك الباف في الواقع استاذ
سامي لانه البعض مع مراجعه الظروف
المعيشيه لبعض الدول الاوروبيه قد تكون
بعض دول الخليج ظروف افضل
افضل لا تكلمت عن الخمسه واربعين فقط 45
واضح استاذ العنقري كيف يمكن تحقيق هذا
الازدهار من بوابه اتفاقيه التقارب
الايراني السعودي بمعنى ان هذه المنطقه
الخليج نعلم بانه منطقه بتروليه وهذا
مفهوم ولكن ما القطاعات الاخرى التي
انتقارب الطرفان فنحن سنرى ربما شراكه
اقتصاديه من نوع مختلف
نحن قلب العالم يعني
امن الطاقه في العالم هو من الخليج بشكل
عام ومن هذه المنطقه سواء في النفط سواء
في الغاز بالاضافه الى الثروات الكبيره
المعدنيه او التعدينيه نحن اليوم مثلا في
المملكه لدينا قطاع التعدين اصبح قطاع هو
الركيزه الثالثه في الاقتصاد السعودي
ونستهدف لا ان يكون فقط تصدير لمواد خام
او وسيطه انما الى منتج نهائي ولذلك يوجد
الان رخص لاكثر من مصنع سيارات مثلا وايضا
هناك مفاوضات لانتاج قطع تستخدم حتى في
صناعات ثقيله في مع شركات عالميه ايضا
لدينا استقطاب واستهداف لنقل المقرات
الاقليميه الى المملكه لانها اكبر اقتصاد
واكبر سوء
ولكن من هذه الشراكه بطريقه خلينا لا
نتحدث عن شراكه بقدر ما نتحدث عن انتفاع
كل طرف من الاخر
ولاطرح سؤالي بطريقه اكثر وضوح ما الذي
يمكن ان تستفيد منه السعوديه مثلا في
تقاربها مع ايران خلينا لا نبدا بايران من
السعوديه تحدثنا عن ذلك كثير ولكن
السعوديه كذلك طرف مهم وطرف رئيسي ما الذي
يمكن ان تضيفه ايران للسعوديه من خلال
بوابه الاقتصاد
باختصار شديد اعتقد ان مجال الامن الملاحي
هي قضيه كبرى تهم الاقليم وتهم العالم كله
بالفعل منطقه الخليج هي احدى الركائز
الاساسيه لتحقيق امن الطاقه لدى العالم
كله
[موسيقى]
وتبحر عبر الممرات الملاحيه والمضائق نسبه
كبيره جدا من حجم التجاره اعتقد
دكتور خالد على
المقاطعه شكرا جزيلا لضيوف الكرام محمد
العقاري كاتب الصحفي الدكتور خالد عكاشه
مدير مركز المصري
والاستاذ الاعلام سابقا السلام عليكم